Having energy all day for different things, ATP and cells are working good.
So if you have energy all day for different things, does that mean your cells are producing
a lot of ATP?
Yeah, I would say so, yeah, but there's other reasons why a person wouldn't have energy.
So you can't just say because I have tired, I'm tired, my mitochondria don't produce
ATP.
That's why.
So I really need to boost my mitochondria.
No, you've got to look at why am I tired?
Do I have anemia?
Do I have a growth of cancer?
If I had a cancer diagnosis, do I have something else serious going on?
Do I have liver congestion?
Do I have detoxification issues?
Do I have, you know, there's food sensitivities and inflammation?
There's just a lot of different reasons why a person would not have energy.
But could you say because I have energy, my mitochondria are working well?
Oh, I guess you could, you know, because I could walk up today and I could breathe, my lungs
are functioning well.
Does it mean they could be functioning better?
Yeah, I don't know, but yes.